all right chosen
chosen uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally los angeles
california
quencher audition south central sure
and tell me about uh your family growing
up you had both your parents
uh both my parents growing up mom's dad
uh five sisters youngest uh five sisters
only boy
no how would you describe your childhood
childhood was lovely it was like
basically i was a kid with a silver
spoon you know i grew up in uh
like the windsor hills area which they
called the black beverly hills
right so good childhood it sounds like
almost different
how far did you go in school i went all
the way in school and had a little bit
of college myself
yeah and today you're you're doing what
today
i'm trying to find another hole to put
on my chain
you've been you've been working as a
pimp since since then well i had my
first home when i was 12 years old
12 12. how'd that go down well i come
from a bloodline apprentice when i've
seen my pedigree my
uncles cousins uh pops
you know i mean i was just a family
trader i adapted you know
uh it's a lifestyle that i live you know
i mean that's my livelihood
it's all on a [ __ ] i'm gonna send a
[ __ ] every time i can and your girls
work figaro or other other
girls work whatever corner they're gonna
work on whatever corner i'll put them on
they're gonna turn it to a track any
corner is a host though
how many girls you got right now i got
three most i ever had was six
my first home was japanese girl i was 12
years old see out of washington
you know uh my cousin money johnny and
ray wright
put me up on her and uh i was learning
the game damn i was taught by uh also a
tq gordy black doll out of
of the pimps will raise money so you're
a 12 year old that's what that's about
uh seventh grade something like that
eight three something like that i would
imagine yeah and you're you're how old
is
the asian girl that you're talking about
in seattle she was 18.
a 12 year old is telling an 18 year old
what to do most definitely from out of
town
most definitely and she's sending you
the money she
she uh first time i sent her
was up in seattle washington hospital
called aurora
and uh my cousin money johnny told me a
little bit of the game and uh
i sat her down out there and told her
give me a call when she ready
about 30 minutes later she called me
said come to this motel
i get to the motel she got a piece some
500
sitting on the nightstand for me i said
damn
let's go get some mo
it's an interesting lifestyle what makes
a girl want to give you her money
and she can keep it herself a girl won't
want to feel that uh
that deadly love she wants to daddy
she wants to be you know directed and
talk
taught how to do things the right way
you know what i mean they knew better
they do better out there
you know a lot of people think you're
basically just
hustling them for their money but i
don't know how do you do it i don't make
a girl give me nothing i don't force a
girl to pimp i don't i'll first grow the
whole filming i don't make
nothing they choose that's why my name
chosen they chosen me
it's the lifestyle i live yeah
yeah i hear that a lot a lot of the
girls are choosing the tips
they choose to do this rather than being
most definitely no is it because
i'm not a guerrilla plump and none is it
because is it because they can't handle
their money very well
well most of them just like that
direction you know what i'm saying to
get them to a better place that they
want to be at
you know you know it excites them for me
personally
[ __ ] don't get my dick hard it's money
to get my get going
you been right before have i been in
love man [ __ ] love
that's my favorite line i ask all the
pimps you've been in love before and
they all have the same exact answer
[ __ ] love yeah that's for that's for
little kids
yeah pretty much did you join any prison
time
almost yeah i just finished doing 14
years what was that for
murder murder yeah
that was related to the game or no yeah
dude who beat my beat one of my hoes
with uh
with uh some jacks and tire jacks
and i put a couple in
[Music]
and the girls you have now you guys live
together or you
well sometimes we together sometimes i
have my different motels
you know stuff like that but for the
most you have a weird family we're
together yeah and when
one of the girls gets in trouble with
one of their tricks what happens
there's consequences to the games rules
to this game and you know if you violate
them rules
it's going to be consequences
what does a girl need to what
personality traits or what does she need
to know in order to do this kind of work
because
this is certainly not a job for any girl
no it's definitely not a job for any
girl you know i mean
she most definitely had to have street
smarts about herself first and foremost
no you know who's the police who's not a
police
who's a good trick who's not a good
trick you know i mean whatever
every ev every every green dick
[ __ ] are marked you know
so a real hoy ain't got to show no [ __ ]
a real hoe will sell conversation and
get paid you know
and i was talking buy a hoe
what makes her a bad trick what makes
her a bad dress
what makes for like a trick that she
does not want to go with
one who don't want to play oh i mean
i mean it is so deep with my lifestyle
it's tattooed all on my back i got a big
old texture on my back say the life of a
pimp
what are you doing when your girls gets
out of line does something you don't
like
well i'm not i'm not into just smashing
smashing on my house but i do keep my
foot on that neck i'm not into beating
on a picture you know man
i do have a mama you know so but uh
it's consequences you know this is
discipline has to happen
yeah and the game has changed over the
years right the game has definitely
changed
actually the game hasn't changed but
there's just different players in the
game but the the game was the same
you know pimping horn been around since
since adam and eve you know i mean
really
[ __ ] that was horn in the biblical days
but the penalties are worse now
absolutely it's a little more dangerous
right
yeah and are some of the girls just
hustling the guys and just like stealing
them with their watch their wallet or
whatever oh yeah you know you got the
things you got successful things you
know
i had one girl she's a damn good thief
she ain't never sold no [ __ ]
she's a damn good thief though you know
she knew how to get a treat
how to get his pants down to his knees
and make him feel like he was an ecstasy
uh
come up out of his pockets with
everything
so what do you what are your thoughts on
karma do you believe
what you're doing is is cool and it's
all fine or is there a price to pay down
the road for
i deal with that when you come you know
i mean i live for the moment because
down the road ain't promised to me
you know life is a promise death is
guaranteed
would you would you ever consider a girl
doing this to you where
you're the one that's making money
giving it to her never gonna just be
giving my money to a [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying so i'm like
worried about that
my mama taught me very well
but you have a clear conscience of what
you're doing absolutely
because i don't i'm not one who makes
her do anything she does it because she
wants to
you know i've had several plenty of hoes
cover me chose now i want to i want to i
want i want to be down with you you know
well it's the chosen fee that come with
me
you talk to me no bread in my hand is
the basis of your relationship romantic
for the girl romance man [ __ ] some
romance
not for you but for the romance me with
some money [ __ ] so it's all about money
it's all about some bread that's what
the whole world is about
money how do you think this [ __ ] was
built on some money
that's the craziest thing you've seen in
your years of doing this
man i see some crazy [ __ ] but
um the craziest [ __ ] i've been saying
oh wow
well [ __ ]
some tricks like different things you
know
some like to be [ __ ] on you know
and uh when i seen that i was like
flabbergasted like really he's like [ __ ]
on him
you know so just make some more [ __ ] and
put it on him and get some more money
the more he pay them all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
buddy what are you proudes of in your
life excuse me what are you proudest of
yourself what am i proud of so
um what am i proud of
my life i just beat a child in my
parents
you have kids of your own i don't have
no kids yeah
what what which of your girls is the
biggest money maker what kind of girl
not necessarily your name but what would
be truthfully i had a transsexual home
for me
and uh so you you you pimp [ __ ] as
well [ __ ] right honest
discrimination you show money it's about
money that's all about money
and and the kings seem to be getting
kinkiers i sat her down on sunset
with my whole chocolate chocolate come
back with me with 900
and there's plenty coming back with me
with four thousand
chocolate get your punk ass off the
front seat [ __ ] get up here let's go
get some more money
the kings get kinky or don't they oh man
oh now that's where the kinky [ __ ] is at
on santa monica where they going at and
these dudes out there
is really something i mean
they're kinky that's all i can say there
what's your opinion of the human
condition when when guys are doing all
this crazy stuff
with prostitutes hey man to each his own
if that's what they like
i'm cool with it as long as i get paid
as long as you get paid and that's
everything's cool that's it that's all
our [ __ ] give me my period
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life most important
listen
trust no [ __ ]
because a [ __ ] is a sight i mean look
look what eve did to adam
she tricked him in the vitamin apple and
the world been [ __ ] up ever since
all right chosen thank you so much for
coming in and talking with me almost
definitely be careful out there
yes sir thank you man
you